[Musik]
auf ganz privaten Bildern gibt er sich
bescheiden dabei ist er einer der
reichsten Männer der
Welt in seinem Werk so heißt es wird der
härteste Stahl
[Musik]
produziert Alfried Grup von Bohlen und
halallbach die grups gelten als
Waffenschmiede des Deutschen
Reiches
der Name ein
Mythos an den selbst die mächtigsten
glaubenink wie
Windhunde
[Musik]
undstah Mythos ist er dadurch geworden
dass es die Waffenproduktion war das war
ja nur ein Teil seiner seines Aufstiegs
und seiner Entwicklung und aber das war
natürlich das was aufgeregt hat der
Produzent von Waffen und besonders
schweren und schwerwiegenden Waffen mit
großen Kanonen und so das hat eigentlich
die Mythos gestiftet und dafür wird ihm
1947 der Prozess gemacht seine Ankläger
werfen ihm Kriegsverbrechen
[Musik]
vor er wurde angeklagt Verbrechen gegen
die Menschlichkeit begangen zu haben ein
zweiter Punkt war die Plünderung fremden
Eigentums in den eroberten
Gebieten geklagt Mitglied in einer
kriminellen Organisation gewesen zu sein
und genau gewusst zu haben was die Nazis
für Verbrechen planen dafür wurde krup
angeklagt der Name krup ihm bringt er
kein
Glück seine erste Ehe scheitert sie
liebte nur sein
Geld seine zweite große Liebe verlässt
ihn
sein Sohn Art wird ein
Exzentriker der in seiner eigenen Welt
lebt einer Märchenwelt in der er sich
zum Ritter schlagen
lässt dieser WN von einem
Königreich ist immer in ihm
gewesen das ist immer das hat sich
wahrscheinlich hat er sich eingebildet
wenn wenn er dann Grupp ist dann ist er
König oder so irgendwie und hat das
abgeewandelt in dieses Königsreich aber
das hat er ja schon vorher gehabt ja der
Schule auch schon gehabt schon als
16-Jähriger sieht Art sein Schicksal
vorher in sein Tagebuch schreibt er ich
habe herausgefunden dass mich ein Fluch
verfolgt der mein Unglück sein wird es
ist der Fluch des
Geldes die Villa Hügel in Essen
Stammsitz der Familie
kup ein gigantischer Bau mit 269
Zimmern Symbol für
Macht und
Einfluss den Alfred Krupp Mitte des 19
Jahrhunderts geschaffen
hat also ich sehe Alfred immer so ein
bisschen als dieses Mittelding zwischen
Genie und Wahnsinn also der hat ja n ein
aubliches unternehmerisches Gespür an
den Tag gelegt allerdings auch an vielen
Stellen also fast hasardeurartig diese
Firma geführt und dann halt immer auch
das quäncheneng Glück dabei gehabt denn
er macht eine geniale Erfindung das
nahtlos geschmiedete eisenbahnrad es
wird das krupsche
Markenzeichen in der beginnenden
Industrialisierung des 19 Jahrhunderts
wird die Firma zu einer wahren
Goldgrube bald beschäftigt gr tausende
von
Arbeit Alfred ist ja nachts durch die
Werkräume gegangen und hat auf jede
Werkbank an der vorbeikam Zettelchen
hinterlassen wo drauf stand Meer morgen
machen sie das aner nächstenwerke Müller
morgen machen sie das das Werk und die
Pflicht dafür das war eins das war sein
Leben deshalb hat sein Arzt auch gesagt
er glaubt der Mann war an der Grenze zum
Wahnsinn und verfällt einer neuen Idee
krup ist der erste der Geschützrohre aus
Stahl baut
krupkanonen halten länger schießen
besser der Waffenschmied verkauft an
Freund und
FET 1870 baut er sich das Haus die Villa
[Musik]
Hügel doch der Erfolg macht einsam seine
Frau läuft ihm Weg verlassen stirbt er
1887 sich und hinterlässt ein schweres
Erbe auf dem Sarkophag steht ganz groß
das höchste Gut des Menschen ist die
Pflicht und damit war gemeint die
Pflicht dem Werk gegenüber diese Pflicht
wurde in die Erziehung sämtlicher Kinder
im Hause
eingeflochten vor allen Dingen in den
Erstgeborenen den der erstgeboren sollte
später die Firma immer übernehmen
Friedrich Alfred K der Sohn nach dem Tod
des Vaters übernimmt er die
Firma und es sind gute Zeiten für das
Werk Kaiser Wilhelm der Z will aufrüsten
er braucht Waffen und eine
Flotte aus
Stahl aus dem Stahlwerk wird ein
Industriegigant um die jahrhundertwände
Arbeiten schon 45000 Menschen für gr
doch glücklich ist Friedrich Alfred
nicht eigentlich der der falsche Mann
oder in der falschen Haut also an sich
jemand der sich für Schöngeistiges
Interessierte an sich jemand der für ja
Meeresbiologie Naturwissenschaften sich
Interessierte und jemand der nie auf die
Idee gekommen wäre in den Stahlbereich
zu gehen selber der industrielle erholt
sich in
Italien
auf der Insel Capri hier macht der
astmatiker nicht nur Urlaub er kümmert
sich auch um
Meeresforschung doch dann kommt er ins
Gerede es soll auf Capri wo er lebte in
einer Kotte kultähnliche Zusammenkünfte
gegeben haben mit jungen Männern und
schon die Andeutung von
Homosexualität war damals
verheerend verheerrend vor allem in
Deutschland am 15 November 1902
behauptet die sozialdemokratische
Zeitung Vorwärts krup sei
homosexuell in der Kaiserzeit ein
straftatband es ist der Abend des 21
november 1902 krup ist
alleine am nächsten Tag ist der
Tod die Todesursache ist umstritten bis
heute also es kein Anzeichen dass er
sich selbst umgebracht haben soll das
also eine wirkliche wilde Behauptung die
durch nichts zu stützen ist wenn man
anfängt da zu
forschen doch letzte Zweifel bleiben
auch in der Familie Glauben Angehörige
an
Selbstmord ich denke dass das schon so
gewesen sein kann eben weil dieses
Homosexualität in der Familie auch
vorkommt nicht nur einmal und das war
natürlich in dem ganzen Thema stolz Ehre
Selbstanspruch der damaligen Zeit ein
fürchterliches Coming Out und er hat
vermute ich schon er hat dann daraus die
Konsequenz gezogen hat gesagt ich kann
mit diesem Stigma nicht leben Friedrich
Alfred hinterlässt zwei Töchter Barbara
links Bertha rechts im Bild das waren
pubertierende Backfische wirklich
ahnungslos und die mussten nun durch
diesen Skandal gebracht werden ohne dass
sie wirklich schaden nahmen viele Jahre
später hat Berta mal erzählt dass über
dieses Thema sie mit ihrer Mutter nie
geredet hat die Villa Hügel ist jetzt in
weiblicher Hand Berta Grupp die Eltere
der beiden Schwestern wird die reichste
Erbin
Deutschlands die damit verbundene
Unfreiheit lernt die 16-jährige schnell
kennen denn das Werk ist zu wichtig für
die mächtigen
der Kaiser will dass ein passender Mann
gefunden wird die Wahl fällt auf einen
Diplomaten Gustav von Bohen und
hallbach ich weiß nur dass er ja auch
ein wahnsinnig disziplinierter Mann war
es galt glaub ich für seine gesamte
Existenz mit berter zusammen sicherlich
immer ein Problem hatte doch ein wenig
zu beweisen dass er ja berter nicht
wegen des Vermögens das Geldes
geheiratet hat und sicherlich auch
dadurch immer sein sein erster bester
Mann sein
wollte er will krupscher sein als ein
krup unter gustav ist alles nach der Uhr
geregelt jede Minute Pflicht und
Disziplin als Firmenleiter darf sich
Gustav nun krup von Bohen und hallbach
nennen ich glaube alle Beteiligten war
froh dass ein präsentabler junger Mann
gefunden war und was ich besonders nett
finde ist ist also ohne Zweifel eine
wilde und große Liebe gew zwischen den
beiden da vorstellt die nächsten 10
Jahren acht
Schwangerschaften doch die erste ist die
wichtigste schon ein Jahr nach der
Hochzeit wird der Stammhalter geboren
Alfried ein fröhliches Kind
noch denn in der großen Villa Hügel ist
für menschliche Wärme kaum
Platz
wenn sie da
reingehen kommen Sie in eine
riesenhle das was also woll wir mal
sagen nicht gerade sehr heimelich ist
aber da hängen lauter große Bilder meist
von der
Familie als Kind haben wir im zweiten
Stock gewohnt also ziemlich abgetrennt
von oberhalb von der oberen Halle
aber richtig wohlgefühlt haben wir uns
nicht es gab ja so gut wie keine
persönlichen Liebesbezeugung zwischen
Eltern und Kindern dass man mal am
Sonntag einfach ins Bett der Eltern
gekrochen kommt und dort irgendwie ein
Buch vorgelesen bekommt oder so das gab
es das
undenkbar materiell fehlt es den Kindern
an nichts sie haben einen eigenen Park
eigene
Reitpferde aber keine
Freiheiten die Kinder hatten feste
Sprechstunden bei ihren Eltern da stand
dann Gustav mit der Taschenuhr so als
Stoppuhr jetzt symbolisiert und dann
wurden die Themen die zu besprechen
waren Erziehungsthemen die wurden dann
sage ich
mal
einseitig besprochen um nicht zu sagen
diktiert dabei trifft es den ältesten
ers kein preußenprinz ist strenger
erzogen worden Gouvernanten und
Angestellte sind auf Schritt und Tritt
präsent bis zu seinem 15 Lebensjahr wird
er von Hauslehrern auf der Villa Hügel
unterrichtet Freunde hat er kaum er hat
nur seine
Familie der hat auch gesagt alles was
ich getan habe hat nicht selber von mir
abgehangen das ist immer von anderen
bestimmt worden und so ist aus ihben
durch diese Erziehung auf ein ganz
bestimmtes Ziel hin die Pflicht dem Werk
gegenüber zu erfüllen nicht seine
Bedürfnisse auszuleben so hat diese
Erziehung dazu geführt dass er ein sehr
verschlossener Mensch geworden ist ein
großer großer
Schweiger
1918 Deutschland hat den ersten
Weltkrieg verloren die Revolution bricht
aus
der Kaiser dankt ab die Wende trifft die
KuPS schwer die Firma steht vor dem
Konkurs Waffen darf sie nicht mehr
produzieren die Wirtschaftskrise trifft
das ganze Land Unruhen sind an der
Tagesordnung Nährboden für radikale
Bewegungen viele legen ihre Hoffnungen
auf einen der ihnen das Heil
verspricht
als Hitler die Macht
übernimmt hält sich in der Villa Hügel
die Begeisterung in Grenzen Bertha Grup
von Bohen und halallbach hielt Hitler
für einen Rüpel hitler war ihr zu
proletarisch und sie war
entsetzt als die Fahne mit den drei
kpringen eingeholt werden musste und die
Hakenkreuzfahne aufgezogen W sie hat da
sogar an dieser Situation bei dieser
Situation
geweint 1934 lädt der Rüpel sich selbst
nach Essen ein
Werksbesichtigung sein Ziel Kunde werden
auf der Villa Hügel doch dort ist nicht
jeder Kunde auch gleich ein
König Hitler wurde empfangen in Essen
nicht in der Hauptverwaltung und es
wurde ihm im warsten des Wortes großer
Bahnhof bereitet aber meine Großmama
berth hat sich ja geweigert ihm zu einem
Essen zu empfangen dieser Herr kommt mir
nicht auf die villügel ein Afron Hitler
ist
erzürnt doch der Zorn verfliegt als bald
natürlich war Hitler auch ein Verehrer
der grupschen
Tradition
begeisterter
technikfeg und er hat weniger mit
gr als mit erich Müller dem
kanonenexerten des Hauses Grup sehr
intensive Fachgespräche geführt und
Hitler ordert Waffen erstmals nach
jahrelanger Unterbrechung produziert
Grup wieder
rüstungsgüte im konjunkturellen
Aufschwung schreibt die Firma wieder
schwarze
Zahlen rüstet Gustav Krupp weil es die
Obrigkeit verlangt
[Musik]
es ist schwer zu zu sagen wie weit die
Taktik geht und wo die Überzeugung dann
anfängt später ist Grupp immer mehr
davon überzeugt dass die Regierung
Hitler für Deutschland
ein Gewinn
ist der junge Student Alfried hat mit
dem Nationalsozialismus kaum Berührungen
fern von Essen von den Pflichten und
Zwängen des Elternhauses genießt er die
freie
[Musik]
Zeit der Sportbegeisterte nimmt 1936 an
den Olympischen Spielen teil er gewinnt
im Segeln die Bronzemedaille und lernt
eine Frau kennen Annelise
Bar ja das Problem war Annelise war ja
schon eine geschiedene Frau und sie ist
dann schwanger geworden ungewollt also
jedenfalls war es nicht geplant und er
hat dann die Konsequenzen gezogen hat
gesagt er heiratet sie sie hat sie
geheiratet weil sie schon schwanger war
dass davon natürlich seine Eltern nicht
so schrecklich begeistert waren das kann
man sich natürlich vorstellen die Idylle
auf dem Familienfoto trügt
also es war ja nicht nur ein ein
subtiles Gefühl sondern es war ja offen
ausgetragener Krieg der dort
stattgefunden hat also Alfried musste
mit seiner jungen Frau ins Nebengebäude
ziehen und durfte als ältester Sohn
nicht mehr im Hauptgebäude mit ihr
wohnen
Annelise ist zu vielen Veranstaltungen
und Gesellschaften nicht eingeladen
gewesen obwohl sie die Frau des ältesten
Sohnes war die Isolation innerhalb der
Familie wird immer
größer den Schwiegereltern ist noch ein
weiterer Umstand ein Dorn im
Auge denn Annelise hat ein
Problem mit dem
Alkohol das ist natürlich dann die Katze
die sich in den Schwanz beißt die
Spirale führt nach unten je mehr sie
trinkt desto weniger wird sie natürlich
geladen oder gerne gesehen und
dementsprechend hat sich das natürlich
dann auch sehr schnell
verselbständigt doch die Missachtung
trifft nicht nur Annelise sondern auch
Ihr Kind den kleinen t dieses Kind ist
an sich nicht
von den Großeltern gewünscht und einer
Angestellte
hat zur Berta kupt zur Oma krup gesagt
Arnt ist doch ein hübsches Kind und da
hat die Berta kupt sie angeherrscht AR
ist für mich kein richtiges
Kind über seine Großmutter schreibt Arm
später in sein Tagebuch sie sei eine
alte einsame Frau beherrscht von den
Intrigen sie war schuld und befahl ihrem
Sohn sich von seiner Gattin zu scheiden
deren Leben am Reichtum
zerbrach Berta setzt sich durch ihr Sohn
Alfred lässt sich scheiden der Alfred
hätte sich mit seiner Mutter nicht
angelegt das war für ihn keine Option zu
sagen Mama das ist mein Leben es ist
meine Frau es ist mein Kind es ist mein
Glück ja hier hast du nicht rumzufuschen
das hat nicht gepasst das haben die
Eltern klar gemacht
unmissverständlich alfri beugt sich den
Familienwerten Pflicht und
gehorsam und seiner Karriere steht
nichts mehr im Weg als Juniorchef erhält
er einen Sitz im Direktorium der
[Musik]
Firma Hitlers Krieg beginnt auch mit
krupschem Material
Polen wird überrollt in nur 5
[Musik]
Wochen mit dem Krieg zieht ein neuer
Geist in das Unternehmen
[Musik]
ein mit dem Beginn des Krieges ist für
Gustav
Grup eine distanzierte Haltung nicht
mehr möglich weil er weiß D jede innere
Distanz und jede
Kritik nicht mehr angemessen sei der
Firma werden vom Regime sollzahlen
vorgelegt die Wehrmacht bestimmt was
produziert
wird doch bald ist die Zeit der
blitzsiege vorbei immer mehr deutsche
Männer müssen an die Front darunter auch
tausende von grruparbeitern die Verluste
steigen auch die Familie kup verliert
Söhne Klaus
und
eegbert der Firma gehen langsam die
Arbeitskräfte
aus die Produktion droht zu
[Musik]
erliegen als Ersatz bietet das Regime
russische Kriegsgefangene und
Zwangsarbeiter sie sollen die Lücken
schließen doch bei krup ist man nicht
begeistert
natürlich haben wir vielen Fällen
versucht zu bremsen ne auch gerade diese
ganze Beschäftigung von auslandsarbeiter
nicht wir haben uns mit Händen und Füßen
dagegen gewehrt aber es war nichts zu
machen n zu machen doch bei Grup will
man die sollzahlen erreichen und nimmt
die Zwangsarbeiter im gesamten Krieg
sind es über 5 Millionen die ins
Deutsche Reich verschleppt werden 150
000 kommen zu Grup über 100 Arbeitslager
werden für die Firma eing
gerichtet für die Nazis sind die Russen
Untermenschen sie gestehen Ihnen nur
hungerrationen zu ein grupparbeiter
schreibt am 18 märz
1942 das ganze Essen war buchstäblich
nur Wasser es geht nicht an dass die
Leute uns hier bei der Arbeit verrecken
die Leute sollen hier für uns arbeiten
gut aber dann muss auch dafür gesorgt
werden ich habe hier verschiedene
Gestalten im Lager gesehen da ist mir
tatsächlich ein kalter Schauer über den
Buckel gelaufen
die Zustände in den Lagern sie ähneln
Bildern wie
diesen auch die Konzernspitze weiß um
die
Verhältnisse sind sie denn überhaupt
irgendwann mal während des Krieges mit
Fremdarbeitern persönlich in berü ich
bin den Lagern gewesen und haben sie da
festgestellt dass es wirklich so
schlecht war stellenweise war es
schlecht denn wir haben darum gekämpft
zusätzlich den Leuten geben die wurden
ja von der s vorher betreut und wie sich
das nannte betreut und versorgt durch
eine besondere Organisation diese
Versorgung war teilweise schlecht wir
haben dann versucht sie zu verbessern ne
das war zunächst nicht zulässig D hat
man hintenrum getan wir haben
Lebensmittel sogar geschmuggelt aus
Holland
Ende
1943 verschlechtert sich der
Gesundheitszustand von Vater Gustav
rapide mit 73 Jahren beschließt er die
Leitung der Firma
abzugeben alfri wird jetzt Herrscher
über das krup Imperium als alleiniger
Inhaber muss er für alles gerade stehen
was im Namen kup
[Musik]
geschieht die letzten Tage des Dritten
Reiches alle Fronten brechen
zusammen für die Panzerproduktion
schickt das Regime nach Essen was ihm
noch zur Verfügung
steht Minderjährige jüdische Mädchen aus
[Musik]
Auschwitz eines Tages kamen es waren
vielleicht zwei drei oder vier Herren
und wir mussten uns
aufstellen und 500 von den 2000 Mädchen
wurden nach Essen
mitgenommen in einem Lager wie diesem
stehen die unterbewachung der
SS täglich werden sie zur Arbeit in die
gruppwerke
getrieben wir dachten nur bekommen wir
zu essen oder hungern wir lassen Sie uns
am Leben oder töten Sie
uns dabei ist die Rettung nicht mehr
fern im März 45 ist Essen schon in
Reichweite der amerikanischen
Artillerie es sind nur noch wenige
Kilometer
doch für die jüdinen soll es keine
Rettung
[Musik]
geben wir hatten nichts zu verlieren und
dachten sogar an flucht weil ein junger
ssmann uns sagte ihr kommt hier nicht
lebend raus die 5 Minuten euch alle zu
erschießen die haben wir
immer in derchen hauptverwaltungind die
Mordpläne der SS bekannt um ein Massaker
auf dem Werksgelände zu verhindern
beschließt das Direktorium die Mädchen
abzuschieben die SS
übernimmt bis zuletzt arbeitet Alfred
für das Regime bleibt aber auf Distanz
er
ist sehr extrem verschlossen und
zurückhalten und erfüllt damit auch
nicht die Hoffnungen die man gerade auch
von politischer Seite Inn gesetzt hat er
war einfach nicht rücksichtslos genug
nicht brutal genug nicht entschlossen
genug doch die Alliierten sehen in ihm
einen wichtigen Förderer und nutznier
der Nazis als sie in Essen
einmarschieren haben sie ein Ziel den
aus ihrer Sicht mächtigsten deutschen
Industriellen
[Musik]
verhaften Alfred ahnt es flüchtet jedoch
nicht
er stellt
sich das Bedürfnis nach Bestrafung bei
den Siegern ist es groß für sie sind
alle KuPS
Kriegsverbrecher die grupfilie
unterstützte mit anderen industriellen
Hitler sie produzierten die Waffen für
seine Weltherrschaft jetzt haben wir sie
eingesperrt diese Familie schon
Waffenschmied im Deutsch-Französischen
Krieg im Ersten Weltkrieg bauten sie
große Geschütze und u-bote für den
Kaiser sie sind für den Tod von
alliierten Soldaten genauso schuldig wie
Hitler und Göring denn durch töten
verdienten sie ihr
Geld Alfred soll in Nürnberg büßen für
den Namen
kup obwohl ihm in keinem Anklagepunkt
individuelle Schuld nachgewiesen wird
let doch auf
ih er erhält 12 Jahre
Haft in der Urteilsbegründung wurde den
Angeklagten insbesondere systematische
Plünderung ausländischen Eigentums und
menschenunwürdige Behandlung von
zivilarbeitern und Kriegsgefangenen zur
Last gelegt Alfred Krups gesamtes
Vermögen einschließlich der krtwerke
fällt der
Beschlagnahme
in der Haft fragt ein junger US-Soldat
Alfred wie er angesprochen werden will
Herr von Bohen oder mit vollem Namen
Herr Krupp von Bohen und hallbach seine
Antwort nennen sie mich Grup wegen
dieses Namens bin ich hier und diese
Zelle ist mein Anteil an dem großen
kruperbe auch das Familienschloss
blübach in Österreich wird von den
Amerikanern
besetzt
hier hatten Annelise und der kleine Arnt
nach der Scheidung Zuflucht
genommen nun müssen sie das Schloss
verlassen und da fragt der siebenjähre T
seine
Mutter warum können wir denn nicht in
blünbach bleiben hier ist es doch so
schön warum müssen wir denn weggehen und
dann sagt sie wir müssen fliehen es geht
nicht hier zu bleiben denn du bist ein
Grupp und da sagt er was ist denn ein
Grupp und da sagt zu ihm das ist etwas
ganz ganz
furchtbares schon früh
instrumentalisiert die Mutter das Kind
er hat seh unter seiner Mutter gelitten
der
T war vielleicht so ein bisschen das
Faust Faustpfand von
annalise er war ja der wirklich der
einzige Grupp
Sohn und Erbe und da sie ja schon sehr
früh geschieden wurde das war so ihr
Pfand sie äh das war auch ihr kleiner
Zahlmeister es war ihr Ehemann Ersatz
Arn kommt in ein Internat nach
Oberbayern anders als sein Vater bekommt
er die Chance unter Gleichaltrigen
aufzuwachsen eigentlich hat er uns eher
ein bisschen leid getan weil wir wussten
dass sein Vater noch im Gefängnis ist
ähm er von seiner Mutter getrennt wurde
die hier durchaus regelmäßig
auftauchte und es ihm das Leben unserer
Meinung nach damals nicht leichter
gemacht hat denn in dem Moment wo er
anfing bisschen in der Gruppe aufzugehen
erschien wieder die Mutter und hat ihm
irgendwelche Privilegien verschafft was
in so einer Gesellschaft und so einer
Gemeinschaft schwierig ist armt zieht
sich zurück er wird zum Einzelgänger und
will kein Gruppen me sein er konnte das
er inrich ich sehe uns oft noch da so in
der Klasse sitzen Pause man wollte nicht
rausgehen dann zeichnete er und er sagte
dann ch ich wäre vielleicht Modezeichner
oder so etwas ja imzwischen ändern sich
die Vorzeichen
1951 der Kalte Krieg hat begonnen die
Alliierten haben nun Interesse an einem
starken Westdeutschland viele Urteile
werden revidiert der amerikanische
hohekommissar
prüft auch den krupfall noch
[Musik]
einmal ich hatte nie das Gefühl dass
mein Vater seine Entscheidung später
bereute für ihn war alfri nicht
verantwortlich für das was in den
kropwerken an Verbrechen
geschah ja er hat den Fall sehr sorgsam
überprüft 2 februar 1951 kommt alfri
Grupp
frei aber 6 Jahre Haft haben Spuren
hinterlassen es war sehr traurig im
ganzen und er konnte sich ja auch nicht
ausdrücken er musste
einfach hat nicht gelächelt und es hat
ihn eigentlich noch reservierter gemacht
als wie er vorher
war in der Freiheit gilt
für beide seit Jahren die erste
Gelegenheit zu einem Vater Sohn
Gespräch und die beiden gingen im
Schulhof vor aller Augen um ein Rondell
immer wieder ganz lange es gibt die
schönsten Spaziergänge dort in
Oberbayern aber ausgerechnet vor aller
Augen gingen die und man hatte nicht das
Gefühl Vater und Sohn zu sehen sondern
eher Herr und
Knecht denn der Vater sieht in seinem
Sohn nicht das Kind sondern den
Nachfolger das ist eig die normale
Reaktion warum hat er ihn nicht mal in
den Arm genommen und ich denke das wäre
auch die Sehnsucht von dem
gewesen
AR flüchtet sich in eine
Traumwelt spielt
Theater er dreht sogar einen eigenen
Film
über die Liebe in der
Pubertät und dabei stellt er fest dass
er sich für Frauen nicht
interessiert in sein Tagebuch schreibt
er manchmal denke ich das Sterben sei
gar nicht so schlimm mein Leben ist
total verpfuscht durch meine
Anlagen und dann hat er sich eben
zurückgezogen hat im Internat noch einen
internen Kreis gebildet
DAU viel jüngere Knaben um sich
versammelt die weich waren mädchenhaft
waren er soll auch mal erwischt worden
sein und muss die Schule wechseln sein
Abitur macht armt in der
Schweiz danach studiert er auf Wunsch
des Vaters BWL gegen seinen
Willen doch dafür wird er in die Familie
aufgenommen der Kronprinz darf jetzt
sogar neben Großmutter Bertha
sitzen und quält
sich ja das ist mein Sohn NT jetzt 23
Jahre alt noch nicht in der Firma tätig
aber er studiert in Köln
Betriebswirtschaft und wird er einmal
das Werk übernehmen ich hoffe dass er es
einmal übernehmen
wird mit in der 50er Jahre versucht
alfreded den angeschlagenen Ruf der
Firma wiederherzustellen nie mehr will
er eine Waffe produzieren die Firma soll
ein neues Gesicht
bekommen dafür holt er sich einen
Manager an die Seite der ihm hilft die
Firma neu zu strukturieren Bertold
Balz Alfred hat da zwar die
Entscheidungen die entscheidenden Dinge
nach wie vor
selbstbestimmt aber er hat das
Tagesgeschäft doch abgegeben also diese
Bewegung weg von der Firma war
gleichzeitig eine Bewegung hin zu seinem
privaten Leben Alfried unternimmt
ausgedehnte segelts oft ist er
wochenlang auf hoher
See und sucht das einfache
[Musik]
Leben an Bord will er Kamerad
sein doch als Eigner des Schiffes hat er
auch mitten auf dem Atlantik eine
Sonderstellung er heiratet ein zweites
Mal Vera
hossenfeld doch auch diese Ehe
scheitert alfri bleibt ein
Einzelgänger danach hat er niemanden
mehr gehabt also Haupt niemanden mehr
ist dann alleine in seinem Haus hat der
da sehr schöne Haus da im hügelpark
gebaut ganz modern und da ist er dann
doch sehr einsam
gewesen nicht weit entfernt von der
Villa Hügel sorgt sich Alfried Krupp von
Bohen und hallbach Mitte der 60er Jahre
um den Fortbestand der
Firma denn seine Gesundheit ist
angegriffen er raucht er war ja ein
Kettenraucher und das machte uns immer
Sorge eine Zigarette wurde an der
nächsten
angezündet und auch das ganze Haus roch
eben wenn man da eintrat nach
Zigarettenrauch april
1967 Alfried weiß dass er nicht mehr
lange leben wird
Lungenkrebs sein letztes Ziel ist die
Firma und sein Privatvermögen in eine
Stiftung zu
überführen weil er weiß dass sein Sohn
nicht der richtige Nachfolger ist doch
offen spricht er mit Ernst darüber
nicht ich denke der Alfried wollte das
Gespräch und konnte es nicht führen ich
glaube aber auch dass der Arn das
Gespräch mit seinem Vater gar nicht
hätte führen
können es ist Berthold Beiz der Arnt
davon überzeugt auf sein Erbe für eine
hohe Abfindung zu
verzichten das ist eigentlich so der
tragische Schlusspunkt unter einer
tragischen Beziehung muss man eigentlich
sagen ich meine jetzt Vater soohn
Beziehung aber damit auch sinnbildtig
unter der ganzen Schlusspunkt dann ja
unter die ganze Familiengeschichte weil
das dann ja auch
der Beginn war des Übergangs in eine
Stiftung die mit dem familiengedanken ja
gar nichts mehr zu tun
hat aber es ist Alf letzte Wille Familie
und Firma werden
getrennt diesen Weg zu gehen ermöglichte
mein Sohn NT durch seinen
Erbverzicht für seine
verantwortungsbereite Einsicht möchte
ich ihm vor aller Öffentlichkeit
ausdrücklich danken möge es ihnen
vergönnt sein die weitere Entwicklung
unserer Firma noch viele Jahre
mitzugestalten und mitzu verfolgen glück
auf
150 Jahre lang waren Firma und Familie
ein der Name kup geriet zum
Mythos die Marke bleibt doch der
Familienname er erlischt mit alfrids Tod
nur wer das Unternehmen führt darf
seinen Namen kup
[Musik]
voranstellen mit Alfred KR von Bohen und
Halbach stirbt am 30 Juli 197
auch der letzte
Grup sein Sohn armt darf den Namen nicht
mehr
führen ich glaub sicher dass er ih sehr
verehrt hat hat er hat mir immer
gesagtte war eine überragende
Persönlichkeit und hat den Buben
verschreckt denke ich mir also er hat
den sicher sicher sehr gern gehabt aber
er hat ihn
gefürchtet für AR beginnt ein neues
Leben jetzt bricht er mit der Familie
mit den noch lebenden Onkeln und
Tanten und er bricht mit sämtlichen
Familientraditionen er er rebelliert
einfach gegen alles was diese Familie
ihm aufoktruiert hat und ihm angetan hat
und er tut es halt auf seine Art um
einfach nach außen hin zu zeigen jetzt
mache ich das was ich will und ich werde
jetzt nicht mehr von dieser Familie mir
wird nicht mehr gesagt was ich machen
muss und was meine Pflicht ist
und ja was so lange in dieser
Familie hochgehalten wurde das hat er im
Endeffekt dann in der Öffentlichkeit
gezielt meines Erachtens auch dann
zerstört
taucht ab in das Leben des
Jetset und heiratet sogar seine beste
Freundin doch eine richtige Ehe ist es
nicht er will der Herrschaft der Mutter
entgehen die sich an ihn klammert ein
Leben lang eine meinesarzt nach fast
gefährliche Frau sehr gescheit sehr gut
ausschauen sehr
elegam aber
herzlos am Ende wird sie ihn sogar für
Geld erpressen
mit Details aus seinem
Privatleben durchlebt die Prophezeiung
die er schon als 16jähriger machte den
Fluch des
Geldes ich persönlich betrachte alles
was mit Geld
zusammenhängt Schlösser
[Musik]
Häuser materielle Dinge eigentlich als
transitorisch ich betrachte
Geld ist alle Menschen geborgt für die
Zeit die er lebt und ich verstehe
Menschen nicht die sich zum Sklaven des
Geldes
machen flüchtet in seine Fabelwelt am
Ende lässt er sich sogar zum Ritter
schlagen da ist er schon sterbenskrank
mundbodenkrebs
also er sagte nur er hat einen Auftrag
für mich er wollte noch mal als König
gemalt sein sag ja er machte ein Safe
auf und holte eine Krone raus und die
setzte er sich also auf und die war
richtig schwer se und er war schon
richtig geschwächt der konnte kaum mehr
gerade stehen also lief die
Schweißperlen liefen em von der Stirn
runter und er spürte auch dass es
irgendwo zu Ende geht und dass sein
Traum wenigstens manifestiert ist
dass dass er der Nachwelt als König
erhalten
bleibt ein König ohne Königreich früh
hatte er auf das stahlimperium
verzichtet und den Namen Grup verloren
doch zeitlebens sah er das immer
anders grub von Bohen und Halbach hat er
geschrieben hat er selber geschrieben so
soll die Todesanzeige sein und ich finde
das auch auch
[Musik]
richtig we das kann ihm keiner nehmen
dass er der letzte Grupp
war und der erste der sich freigemacht
hat von den Zwängen seiner
Vorfahren Kop Mythos und Wahrheit einer
deutschen
[Musik]
Familie